[Music]
imagine aliens land on the planet a
million years from now and look into the
geologic record what will these curious
searchers find of us they will find what
geologists scientists and other experts
are increasingly calling the
Anthropocene or new age of mankind
the impacts that we humans make have
become so pervasive profound and
permanent that some geologists argue we
merit our own epoch that would be a new
unit in the geologic timescale that
stretches back more than 4.5 billion
years or ever since the earth took shape
modern humans may be on a par with the
glaciers behind various ice ages or the
asteroid that doomed most of the
dinosaurs what is an epoch most simply
it's a unit of geologic time there is
the Pleistocene an icy epoch that saw
the evolution of modern humans or
there's the Eocene more than 34 million
years ago a hothouse time during which
the continents drifted into their
present configuration changes in climate
or fossils found in the rock record help
distinguish these epochs and help
geologists tell deep time so what will
be the record of modern peoples impact
on the planet it doesn't rely on the
things that may seem most obvious to us
today like sprawling cities even New
York or Shanghai may prove hard to find
buried in the rocks a million years from
now but humans have put new things into
the world that never existed on earth
before like plutonium and plastics in
fact the geologists known as
stratigraphy
who determine the geologic time scale
have proposed a start date for the
Anthropocene around 1950 that's when
people started blowing up nuclear bombs
all around the world and scattering
novel elements to the winds those
elements will last in the
record even in our bones and teeth for
millions of years and in just 50 years
we've made enough plastic at least 8
billion metric tons to cover the whole
world in a thin film people's farming
fishing and forestry will also show up
as a before-and-after in any such strata
because it's those kinds of activities
that are causing unique species of
plants and animals to die out this
die-off started perhaps more than 40,000
years ago as humanity spread out of
Africa and reached places like Australia
kicking off the disappearance of big
likable and edible animals this is true
of Europe and Asia think woolly mammoth
as well as North and South America too
for a species that has only roamed the
planet for a few hundred thousand years
Homo sapiens has had a big impact on the
future fossil record that also means
that even if people were to disappear
tomorrow evolution would be driven by
our choices to date we're making a new
homogenous world of certain favored
plants and animals like corn and rats
but it's a world that's not as resilient
as the one it replaces as the fossil
record shows it's a diversity of plants
and animals that allows unique pairings
of flora and fauna to respond to
environmental challenges and even thrive
after an apocalypse that goes for people
too if the microscopic plants of the
ocean suffer as a result of too much
carbon dioxide say we'll lose the source
of as much as half of the oxygen we need
to breathe
then there's the smudge in future rocks
people's penchant for burning coal oil
and natural gas has spread tiny bits of
soot all over the planet that smudge
corresponds with a meteoric rise in the
amount of carbon dioxide in the air
now beyond 400 parts per million or
higher than any other homo sapiens has
ever breathed
similar suit can still be found in
ancient rocks from volcanic fires of 66
million years ago a record of the
Cataclysm touched off by an asteroid at
the end of the Late Cretaceous epoch so
odds are our suit will still be here 66
million years from now easy enough to
find for any aliens who care to look of
course there's an important difference
between us and an asteroid a space rock
has no choice but to follow gravity we
can choose to do differently and if we
do there might still be some kind of
human civilization thousands or even
millions of years from now not a bad
record to hope for if you're interested
in learning more about the impact we're
having on the planet
we recommend the unnatural world by
David Biello the author of this lesson
thanks for watching
[Music]